wie viele Leute müssten wir abschieben
150.000 oder 50.000 wie viele sind also
bei den bei den 50.000 kommt dazu wir
haben sehr schlechtes Datenmaterial es
kommt auch dazu ja auch eine ein
Versagen über viele viele Jahre gilt
übrigens auch europaweit dass das
Datenmaterial nicht wirklich gut ist
aber wir können bei den bei den 50.000
die die keinen Status haben auf die
spielen sie wahrscheinlich an
bei denen ist es zum Teil so dass da
auch welche dabei sind die bereits
ausgereist sind da sind auch welche
dabei die ohne Duldung in Haft sind also
es sind nicht alle eins zu eins
zurückzufinden
Offensive und wissen nicht genau wie
viele Leute wir eigentlich zurück führen
wollen
wir haben eine Größenordnung können Sie
sagen von von 50 60.000 wo es
möglicherweise
schneller geht und und eher möglich ist
als bei anderen ja okay
[Musik]